the average income in the us is 54 000
55 000. the top one percent of earners
in america make 450 000 a year and above
if you make 450 000 a year in america
you are very very very wealthy we don't
even begin to think somebody's got
anything going on if they don't make a
million a year and a million a year in
all the craziness now feels like nothing
right so i think we have the
conversation super wrong and then
there's a whole nother combo do you have
any miserable [ __ ] i know that make
four million a year and hate their life
and everything sucks [ __ ] and do you
know how many people that make a buck 30
or 65 that i know that love life like we
have a complete [ __ ] up combo of what
success looks like it's [ __ ] we need to
have important conversations around
self-esteem and fomo and all this other
[ __ ] like if your happiness is
predicated on if people think you're
awesome or or this that you're going to
be in trouble you're vulnerable to
outside affirmation which is the
quickest way to get into a [ __ ] spot